now who's America is this
the people in power who act like it's
theirs to give away to the highest
bidders Wall Street Big Tech the big
donors because they want a certain set
of policies and they usually get their
way sucking up to China I don't want to
contain China I just want to make sure
we have a relationship with China that
is on the up and up squared away
funneling tens of billions to Ukraine we
are always preparing a new military
package for Ukraine as you know we do
these presidential drawdown packages
essentially every couple of weeks
millions of illegal immigrants streaming
across the border
we have responded with a model approach
that has proven to work
policies are ravaging America but
Democrat policy makers so far haven't
cared it's their America to shape and to
control and frankly to give away it's
not yours to defend and enjoy
but things on the surface at least may
be changing now last night we told you
that Democrats had begun serious
conversations about whether a Biden
Harris ticket is really their best shot
at this point for keeping power a
well-respected liberal columnist for the
Washington Post wrote what many
Democrats are privately thinking that
Biden must step aside for the good of
his party and tonight we sense the winds
may be shifting on the policy front as
well
the warning again delivered via a
Washington Post column written by
another prominent globalist Fareed
Zakaria Biden's efforts have amounted to
Band-Aids on a massive open wound he
says about immigration the president
must use the power he has to stop Asylum
Seekers while the system tries to
process the millions of cases
outstanding wow now that's coming from
Fareed Zakaria and that is huge now his
words when I was reading this sounded
like they were ripped out of an old
angle from 2021 when I was warning that
an open border would break America and
break the bide Administration he said
the migrant crisis is exposing
Democratic policy weakness at every
level an Administration that is scared
to take on its Progressive Wing right to
shelter rules that are utterly
unworkable in New York and Massachusetts
now that is quite the about face from a
columnist and CNN hosts to just a month
ago or so declared that there was no
border crisis because the Biden
administration's border plan worked
so in one month Zakaria went from no
crisis to we must change course
what the heck happened
by the way back in 2018 Zakaria was
dabbling in the usual liberal invective
when he examined the motivation of all
of us border Hawks
some of this might be rooted in racism
but it also represents a kind of
heightened nationalism a more emotional
conception of the nation and immigration
has become a proxy for that gut feeling
the sense of the country must be able to
Define itself choose whom it will allow
to come in and privilege its own
citizens over foreigners
of course racism isn't what's at play
here but he got that last part right and
I'd go further We Believe America's
future should be determined by its own
citizenry not by a Cadre of Elites who
want both cheap labor and to permanently
change our electorate by turning our
nation into what Teddy Roosevelt warned
would become what a polyglot boarding
house if borders were not controlled
of course far left politicians like AOC
well they just want to streamline this
never-ending illegal population coming
into the country she spoke today but
they weren't all adoring fans in the
audience
allow for work authorizations so that
the folks in here can get to work and
start supporting themselves as soon as
possible the faster that folks can
access the work that they're asking for
legally the better we can solve this
problem
how does she like them apples and Jerry
Nadler got an earful as well
welcome immigrants here and our cities
are Testament to the many immigrant
communities that have shaped their past
and are propelling us into the future
that's New York my friends
now these Democrats care more about the
Border Crashers sucking up city and
state resources than they care about
American citizens and legal immigrants
struggling to pay their own bills
American Dream will not be bullied into
submission today we will continue to
fight for the American dream we will not
be bullied will we not be pushing to a
corner that way bullied and pushed into
a corner is exactly how the American
people feel over the Border issue
they're gonna keep coming here if the
entire world knows that they're giving
everything for free and queens and in
Manhattan there's gonna be a line from
here all the way to South America it's
never going to end we need to close the
border we can't afford this our city is
going to go bankrupt how are we supposed
to raise families here and they're
calling us races they're calling us
White supremacists
Americans see what's happening here and
many now feel like they're second-class
citizens in their own country like we're
strangers in a foreign land here
no American in his right mind supports
what's happening now
just this week and one day 9 100
migrants cross the border in Arizona 7
400 of them illegally and those are the
ones we know about that's it there are
others who got away sources told Fox
that agents apprehended over 7 400
illegal immigrants at the border on
Tuesday when combined with the
encounters at the ports of Entry that
number hit 9 100. now no wonder the
issue of immigration has become such a
problem now for Biden because in the
most recent CBS you gov poll a whopping
two-thirds disapproved of his handling
of immigration only 34 percent approved
among Republicans 91 percent disapproved
74 percent of Independents disapproved
but out of touch Democrats somehow 66
percent of them think scenes like this
are just fine yeah looking good
those numbers are worse than they appear
by the way because as I intimated at the
outset Republicans opinions on Biden's
handling of immigration broke down along
partisan lines which brings us back to
Zakaria
smart enough to see that this situation
isn't sustainable he's not a dummy it's
not sustainable politically or
practically and the angle believes that
the White House may be may be
considering a move to at least have the
appearance of tightening things at the
border now just so you understand this
this is not because somehow Joe Biden
who doesn't think about anything or any
of the people puppets puppeteers
controlling Biden have some policy
Epiphany on the issue but because it's
become a huge political liability to
them in both the presidential race but I
think it's becoming a liability down
ballot as well
but the fact is the damage that this
open border has already done to America
it's incalculable
Democrats who don't listen to Zakaria
and don't reverse their stance on this
should never be allowed near a position
of power again and that's the angle hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else